jetzt warten noch mal bleibt stehen
hallo das ist das hier
da steckst du dich hier tue mich
erschreckt
das ist nicht witzig
hey leute ich hier ich glaube ihr kennt
es alle die hände zittern das herz rast
man atmen schneller und kalter schweiß
tritt aus
die symptome von angst sind bei den
meisten menschen gleich und das aus
gutem grunde denn aus evolutionärer
sicht sichern uns diese körper
mechanismen das überleben spürt man zum
beispiel eine schlange direkt neben
seinem fuß da passieren im körper
mehrere dinge schnell hintereinander
zuerst schlägt das autonome nervensystem
alarm
es sitzt im stammhirn und kontrolliert
dinge wie den herzschlag die atmung die
schweissdrüsen und die inneren
augenmuskeln und all diese dinge werden
bei gefahr alarmiert um den körper in
höchstleistung zu bringen
die frequenz von herzschlag und atmung
wird erhöht um mehr sauerstoff zu den
muskeln befördern zu können
die pupillen weiten sich und dass sie
und hörvermögen wird empfindlicher und
gleichzeitig schützen die nebennieren
eine menge adrenalin aus und für eine
kurze zeit ist man stärker schneller und
aufmerksamer als üblich all das passiert
automatisch und innerhalb von wenigen
sekunden nach dem schock es ist eine
körperreaktion die experten flight
nennen kämpfe oder 4
diese reaktionen haben unseren vorfahren
immer wieder das leben gerettet
steinzeitmenschen die nicht reagiert
haben überlebten seltener und die
regierung ging mit der zeit verloren
so entwickelte sich über hunderttausende
von jahren ein katalog angefahren und
entsprechenden körperreaktionen die für
diese gefahren die meisten
überlebenschancen bieten
und deswegen ist es auch nicht
verwunderlich dass die vier häufigsten
ängste heutzutage die angst vor spinnen
die angst vor großen höhen die angst vor
engen räumen und die angst vor spitzen
gegenständen alle sehr reale bedrohungen
für die menschen der vergangenheit war
aber wenn uns ein schock hilft der
gefahr zu entkommen
wieso sagt man dann du hast mich zu tode
erschreckt kann so etwas wirklich
passieren
der neurologe martinez m yours von recom
and women's hospital in boston sammelt
seit jahren hunderte von fällen in denen
ganz normale gesunde menschen aus purer
angst gestorben sind zum beispiel auf
achterbahnfahrten oder bei kleineren
autounfällen die sonst komplett ohne
verletzungen geblieben wären
ein schüler aus indien stark sogar weil
er zu viele horrorfilme hintereinander
gesehen hatte und sich dann im
badezimmer wortwörtlich zu tode
erschreckt hat aber was passiert
eigentlich genau im körper
er leitet man einen schock werden die
zwei stresshormone adrenalin und
cortisol ausgeschüttet wenn der shop zu
groß ist und aus den nebennieren mehr
adrenalin ausgestoßen wird
als der körper aufnehmen kann dann wirkt
das hormon giftig und beschädigt
eventuell lunge leber und nieren aber
vor allem das herz bringt das adrenalin
dann zum beispiel in das muskelgewebe
des herzens ein
dann hilft es den muskeln erst einmal
sich stärker zusammen zu ziehen und mehr
blut durch die adern zu pumpen wenn das
adrenalin bei einem großen schock aber
nicht aufhört und immer weiter das herz
blutet kann sich dieses nicht mehr
entspannen und der rhythmus des
herzschlags geht verloren
das nennt man dann auch kammerflimmern
und kann in manchen fällen zum tod
führen
dabei können gesunde menschen genauso
getroffen werden die menschen mit
herzfehlern wissenschaftler sind noch
dabei zu untersuchen welche faktoren
genau das risiko sich zu tode zu
erschrecken erhöhen und welche nicht
wie gefährlich die situation dabei
wirklich ist ist eigentlich vollkommen
egal ob man ohne fallschirm aus dem
flugzeug fällt und quasi keine
überlebenschancen hat oder ob man nur
ein horrorfilm guckt und eigentlich weiß
dass einem nichts passieren kann
die menge an adrenalin die ausgestoßen
wird hängt nur von der art und weise ab
wie man die situation wahrnimmt
als ich am anfang des videos in der
hütte gepackt wurde gab es ein lautes
geräusch zusammen mit der hand die
hinter mir aufgetaucht ist wird das
vielleicht einige von euch erschreckt
haben
in horrorfilmen und auch ein horror
games nennt man so etwas einen jumps gea
es ist eine simple aber sehr effektive
methode um dem zuschauer eine reaktion
zu entlocken
denn die passiert im stammhirn dem
bereich unseres gehirns den wir nicht
kontrollieren können unser körper
reagiert automatisch auf das laute
geräusch ein abwehrmechanismus viele
finden samstags deswegen auch eine
billige methode um angst zu erzeugen
eine elegantere methode ist es eine
neuronale verbindungen herzustellen
könnt ihr euch noch an das geräusch
erinnern dass vor dem samstag kam
ich habe in euren köpfen eine verbindung
geschaffen und zwar zwischen diesem
geräusch und dem gefühl des schocks
diese verbindung ist nach einem mal
zugegebenermaßen noch schwach aber je
häufiger man diese verbindung benutzt
also ich häufiger man den sound mit
einem schock verbindet desto stärker
wird die neuronale verbindungen
das funktioniert für alles mögliche das
gehirn lernt auf diese art und weise
häufig benutzte strecken im gehirn
werden immer weiter verstärkt und genau
das nutzen gute horrorfilme aus wenn die
verbindung erst einmal gelegt wurde gibt
es später im film dann den so genannten
pay off wenn der sound abgespielt wird
und der zuschauer unterbewusst damit
rechnet jeden moment erschreckt zu
werden
obwohl dieser schreck niemals kommt
diese art von angst ist anders es ist
der horror
er sitzt auf einer ebene des gehirns die
kognitiv versteht woher die angst kommt
wenn irgendetwas nicht ganz richtig ist
häufig befinden sich diese momente dann
im an kenny valley das ist der ort an
dem dinge fast normal fast menschlich
aber an den irgend etwas nicht ganz
stimmt
puppen zum beispiel sie sollen menschen
darstellen sind aber definitiv plastisch
und unaids
ihre augen sind tot und dieses nah dran
aber irgendwie doch anders verleiht
puppen dieses unangenehme gefühl
sie sitzen im an kenny berlin hinzu
kommt dass ältere horrorfilme bereits
häufig puppen als horror symbol benutzt
haben und damit bereits neuronale
verbindungen gelegt haben wir erwarten
von puppen inzwischen dass sie uns angst
einflößen
im weiteren sinne profitieren übrigens
alle filme von den vorherigen filmen
eine quietschende tür winter eulen und
ein knacks nach fußboden sind inzwischen
universelle anzeichen für einen
gruseligen teil im film und lassen den
zuschauer bereits voraus ahnen was bald
kommen wird
ob man den zuschauer nun erschreckt oder
nicht ist fast schon egal denn solange
man erwartet geschockt zu werden ist
auch die körperreaktion da erhöhter
pulsschlag zitternde hände schnelles
atmen
der zuschauer spürt einen angst rausch
bereit wegzurennen oder zu kämpfen
auch wenn das im falle von horrorfilmen
gar nicht nötig ist warum so viele
menschen diesen angst rausch gut finden
und gerne horrorfilme gucken ist ein
thema für ein anderes video und wird mir
ehrlich gesagt immer ein rätsel bleiben
aber wie ist das bei euch schaut ihr
gerne horrorfilme und wenn ja wieso
schreibt es mir und in die kommentare
und empfiehlt vielleicht den anderen
zuschauern euren lieblings horrorfilmen
für mich war es dass ich bin sehr direkt
fürs zuschauen und bis nächste woche
donnerstag